[Music]
Gregor Mendel's experiments were a
breakthrough in the field of biology as
they helped in laying the foundation of
genetics questions like why do kids look
similar to their parents and why are
there a few differences in two kids that
belong to the same parents started
gaining answers we now have understood
the monohybrid cross and the monohybrid
ratio as well this is how it's done take
a moment to review it how did we get the
f1 generation we caught it by
considering all the possible
combinations here but is there a method
to find it systematically there is so
before moving ahead with the dihybrid
cross and ratio let's have a look at an
extremely important and useful method
for writing a cross the method is named
as punnett square you may wonder as to
why do we need another method for a
theoretical cross when we already know
how a cross is carried out
well that's because this method is quite
useful in many ways the technique was
developed by the British geneticist
Reginald Punnett hence it's most
commonly known as punnett square let's
understand the techniques step by step
first the first thing we do is make a
table like this we write the symbols of
male and female here these can be
written vice-versa as well but for now
we write it like this this tells us that
the maternal alleles will be written
here while the paternal alleles will be
written here so let's begin the crossing
now this leaf can come together with
this one to give us the set of genes in
the offspring these two can give us this
set this one will combine with this to
give us this set and what about the last
one yes you guessed it right these two
alleles will give us this set in the
spring it's a simple concept of
respective row and column pairing for
each slot for the slot it's the first
row and the first column
for this slot it's the first row and the
second column pairing and so on please
understand this well because it's going
to help us a lot in the future now if we
compare the simple cross that we usually
carry out this is what we get notice
that the results are exactly the same
all the plants in the f1 generation are
tall and have the same genotype they are
all heterozygous this confirms that a
cross is correct a glance at the
presentation of this cross hints at one
more name for it yes this technique is
also referred to as the checkerboard
method now let's do this cross one more
time to know whether we've understood it
correctly
let's cross any two from the f1
generation now again we first draw these
lines to form a table and write the male
and the female symbols here now it's the
turn of the genes so we write the
respective genes here and here shall we
begin crossing now why don't you try
filling in these four slots here we go
these are the combinations that we
obtain on crossing these plants take a
moment to go through this table can you
find the phenotypic and the genotypic
ratios here phenotype if you remember
refers to the observable physical
properties we can clearly see that there
are three tall plants and one dwarf
plant so the phenotypic ratio is 3 s to
1 what about the genotype there is one
homozygous tall case two heterozygous
tall cases and one homozygous recessive
case so the genotypic ratio is 1 to 2 to
1 aren't these the mono hybrid ratios
yes they are
we get exactly the same results that we
obtained on crossing the f1 generation
previously so this is how monohybrid
cross can be carried out using the
punnett square method can you guess why
this method is used when we can cross
the alleles directly yes of course we
can find it directly but that's because
a monohybrid cross involves the crossing
of a single character at a time hence
it's easy but what about the crosses
that involve more than one character an
increase in the number of genes can make
the crossing a bit complicated say we
have 2 or 3 genes and do you think a
simple cross like this will be
convenient to carried out because not it
will be a huge mess so in order to
simplify this we make use of a punnett
square this method is simple and
extremely useful when more than one
alleles are involved talking about
crosses involving more than one
character what are the crosses involving
two characters called the cross
involving two characters at a time is
called dihybrid cross and the ratio of
taint will be a dihybrid ratio let's
understand this interesting concept in
the next part
here is a representative monohybrid
cross on our screen which involves only
one character at a time do you think
crossing a single character at a time
was enough for Mendel to arrive at
concrete conclusions of course not
after all the seven pairs of contrasting
characters were crossed individually
Mendel went a step ahead and crossed
plants considering two characters at a
time he tried the dihybrid cross let's
take a simple example to understand how
the dihybrid cross works which two
characters should we take now we've
already seen a monohybrid cross four
characters like the plant height and the
flower color individually so let's
consider these characters together to
understand the dihybrid cross for our
convenience we take one plant which has
both dominant characters while the other
with both having recessive characters it
means we take both the flats which are
homozygous any guesses about what the
genotypes will be T TPP in uppercase
will be this plant which is tall with
purple colored flowers similarly T TPP
in lowercase will represent a plant that
is dwarf and has white colored flowers
this is how we separate the gametes any
idea why don't we write it as T T and P
P the alias T and T represents the same
trait so they will have to be
distributed in the respective gametes
they will not get together in the same
cell similarly P and P will get into the
separate cells as they are the alleles
for the same trait flower color it's the
same case in the other plant as well
this is how the gametes will be formed
now we're ready for the crossing this is
how the f1 generation would look take a
moment to understand this now to get a
cluesive result we need to cross the
offsprings from the f1 generation and
get the f2 generation let's pick any
from the f1 generation can you tell me
how the gametes will be formed here the
gametes can be formed in these four
different combinations for each case did
you notice what happened will it be easy
to do the crossing here definitely not
that is the reason why we opted for
punnett square for a dihybrid cross
let's get started with a cross for
obtaining the f2 generation we write the
male and the female symbols first
followed by this we write the respective
gametes here and here and how to be
cross these to fill in the 16 slots we
cross each row and column respectively
here this TP is crossed with this TP so
we obtain this slot similarly we cross
this TP with TP to get this offspring
can you try filling in the 3rd and the
4th slots in the first column we cross
this TP with this TP to obtain this
offspring and lastly we cross this TP
with this TP to obtain this one all four
as we can see in the table are tall with
purple flowered plants that's because
there is at least one capital T and one
capital B in each case if you wish to
you could pause the video to fill in the
other 12 slots on similar lines these
are the results that we obtained in the
other slots take a moment to go through
all of these let's count the different
combinations now these are the four
different possible combinations tall
with purple slot plants
tall with white flood plants do off with
purple slot plants and dwarf with white
flower plants now can you count the
number of plants that are tall and with
plus we have nine plants which are tall
and with purple colored flowers can you
count the number of plants for the other
three combinations three plants show the
tall trait along with white flowers and
three show the dwarf trait along with
purple flowers six plants in all have
mixed characters of the parents from the
P one generation it means at least one
recessive character is seen in these six
plants now the last one among the
sixteen shows both the recessive traits
a plant which is dwarf and has white
flowers so if taken together then we
obtain a ratio 9 2 3 2 3 2 1
this ratio is referred to as the
dihybrid ratio now Nora has a simple
question for you whenever any two
characters are randomly taken for a
cross do we obtain the same ratio say we
take the seed color and the seed shape
will we obtain the same ratio well if
the process carried out correctly then
we are bound to get 9 2 3 2 3 2 1
as the dihybrid ratio so if there are 16
plants obtained in the f2 generation
then 9 of them on an average will
express both the dominant characters
like the tall height and the purple
colored flowers in this case 6 plants on
an average will express a blend of both
the characters dominant and recessive
just like these 3 expressing tall height
and white flowers and these 3 showing
dwarf height and purposes lastly only
one out of the 16 shows both recessive
characters do you think we always get
exactly 16 plants in the f2 generation
no not at all there are numerous seeds
obtained which are then sown and plants
are grown to observe these results did
Mendel get only 16 plants in the f2
generation this is also not the case
l had obtained many seeds but when he
grew plants from them he obtained the
plants in certain numbers when these
numbers were calculated the ratio turned
out to be 9 2 3 2 3 2 1
so basically 9 2 3 2 3 2 1 is the ratio
obtained at the end of the calculations
the total number of seeds and dust the
plants obtained could be much higher do
watch our videos based on ratios if you
want to understand them better so 9 2 3
2 3 2 1 is the phenotypic ratio for a
dihybrid cross before we get deeper in
experiments let's have a look at the
lost put forth by Mendel based on the
observations of mono hybrid and dihybrid
crosses Mendel established three
extremely important laws in genetics
let's have a look at them in the next
part so don't forget to subscribe to our
YouTube channel in order to get notified